me and Lillard was having a terrible day
leading up to his record-breaking 71
Point night everything went wrong he
woke up late missed his routine
treatment appointment he didn't have
time to go out for his pregame meal so
he just ordered it except the delivery
person got lost and it only gets worse
from here he scheduled his driver for
the wrong time he lost his NBA All-Star
Three-Point Contest trophy which he was
supposed to bring to the game so he sent
his mom to his house to find it which
she couldn't he also forgot his HBCU
sweatshirt for HBC unite and had to go
all the way to the practice facility to
go and get it now athletes like routine
and there was nothing routine about this
day and even after dropping 71 points he
had to finish the day by getting his
blood drawn for a random drug test and
he hates needles